Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I am a light transport simulation researcher
by trade, and I am very happy today, because we
have an absolutely amazing light transport paper
we’re going to enjoy today. As many of you know,
we write these programs that you can run on your
computer to simulate millions and millions of
light rays, and calculate how they get absorbed or
scattered off of our objects in a virtual scene.
Initially, we start out with a really noisy image,
and as we add more rays, the image gets clearer
and clearer over time. We can also simulate
sophisticated material models in these programs.
A modern way of doing that is
through using these material nodes.
With these, we can conjure up a ton of
different material models and change
their physical properties to our liking. As you
see, they are very expressive indeed, however,
the more nodes we use, the less clear it becomes
how they interact with each other. And as you see,
every time we change something, we have to wait
until a new image is rendered. That is very time
consuming, and more importantly, we have to have
some material editing expertise to use this.
This concept is very powerful, for instance, I
think if you watch the Perceptilabs sponsorship
spot at the end of this video, you will be very
surprised to see that they also use node groups,
but with theirs, you don’t build material
models, you can build machine learning models.
What would be really cool if we could just give
the machine a photo and it would figure out how
to set these nodes up so it looks exactly like
the material in the photo. So, is that possible,
or is that science fiction? Well, have a look our
paper, called Photorealistic Material Editing.
With this technique, we can easily create these
beautiful material models in a matter of seconds,
even if we don’t know a thing
about light transport simulations.
It does something that is similar to
what many call differentiable rendering.
Here is the workflow, we give it a bunch
of images like these, which were created on
this particular test scene, and it guesses what
parameters to use to get these material models.
Now, of course, this doesn’t make any
sense whatsoever, because we have produced
these images ourselves, so we know exactly what
parameters to use to produce this. In other words,
this thing seems useless. And now comes the magic
part, because we don’t use these images. No-no!
We load them into Photoshop, and edit them to our
liking, and just pretend that these images were
created with the light simulation program. This
means that we can create a lot of quickly, really
poorly executed edits. For instance, the stitched
specular highlight in the first example isn’t very
well done, and neither is the background of the
gold target image in the middle. However, the
key observation is that we built a mathematical
framework, which makes this pretending really
work! Look, in the next step, our method proceeds
to find a photorealistic material description
that, when rendered, resembles this target
image, and works well even in the presence
of these poorly executed edits. So these
materials are completely made up in Photoshop,
and it turns out, we can create photorealistic
materials through these node graphs that look
almost exactly the same. Quite remarkable.
The whole process executes in 20 seconds.
If you are one of the more
curious Fellow Scholars out there,
this paper and its source code are
available in the video description.
Now, this differentiable thing has a lot
of steam. For instance, there are more
works on differentiable rendering. In this
other work, we can take a photo of a scene,
and a learning-based method turns the
knobs until it finds a digital object
that matches its geometry and material
properties. This was a stunning piece of work,
from Wenzel Jakob and his group, of course, who
else. They are some of the best in the business.
And we don’t even need to be in the area of light
transport simulations to enjoy the benefits of
differentiable formulations, for instance, this
is differentiable physics. So what is that?
Imagine that we have this billiard game, where
we would like to hit the white ball with just
the right amount of force and from the right
direction, such that the blue ball ends up close
to the black spot. Well, this example shows that
this is unlikely to happen by chance, and we have
to engage in a fair amount of trial and error
to make this happen. What this differentiable
programming system does for us is that we can
specify an end state, which is the blue ball
on the black dot, and it is able to compute the
required forces and angles to make this happen.
Very close.
So after you look here,
maybe you can now guess what’s next
for this differentiable technique…it
starts out with a piece of simulated ink
with a checkerboard pattern, and it exerts
just the appropriate forces so that it forms
exactly the Yin-Yang symbol shortly after.
And now that we understand what
differentiable techniques are capable of,
we are ready to proceed to today’s paper. This is
a proper, fully differentiable material capture
technique for real photographs. All this needs
is one flash photograph of a real-world material.
We have those around us in abundance, and
similarly to our previous method, it sets up
the material nodes for it. That is a good thing,
because I don’t know about you, but I do not want
to touch this mess at all. Luckily, we don’t have
to, look! The left is the target photo, and the
right is the initial guess of the algorithm,
that is not bad, but also not very close.
And now, hold on to your papers and just look at
how it proceeds to refine this material until it
closely matches the target. And with that, we have
a digital representation of these materials. We
can now easily build a library of these materials
and assign them to the objects in our scene.
And then, we run the light simulation
program, and here we go. Beautiful.
At this point, if we feel adventurous, we can
adjust small things in the material graphs to
create a digital material that is more in line
with our artistic vision. That is great, because
it is must easier to adjust an already existing
material model than creating one from scratch.
So what are the key differences
between our work from last year,
and this new paper? Our work made a rough initial
guess and optimized the parameters afterwards,
it was also chock full of neural networks,
it also created materials from a sample,
but that sample was not a photograph, but
a photoshopped image. That is really cool,
however, this new method takes an almost
arbitrary photo, many of these we can take
ourselves or even get them from the internet,
therefore this new method is more general.
It also supports 131 different
material node types, which is insanity.
Huge congratulations to the
authors, if I would be an artist,
I would want to work with this right
about now. What a time to be alive!
So there you go, this was quite a ride, and I
hope you enjoyed it just half as much as I did.
And if you enjoyed it at least as much as I did,
and you feel a little stranded at home and are
thinking that this light transport thing is pretty
cool, and you would like to learn more about it,
I held a Master-level course on this topic
at the Technical University of Vienna.
Since I was always teaching it to a handful of
motivated students, I thought that the teachings
shouldn’t only be available for the privileged
few who can afford a college education, but
the teachings should be available for everyone.
Free education for everyone, that’s what I want.
So, the course is available free of charge
for everyone, no strings attached, so make
sure to click the link in the video description
to get started. We write a full light simulation
program from scratch there, and learn about
physics, the world around us, and more.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!